hi guys i am gregory alba with me is a
lovely stacy Howard hi guys Gregory
Alvin it's a very formal pronunciation
of your name
Oh like you said the whole thing you're
not like hey I'm Greg like you just had
to be really fun I want to be relatable
okay be like hey Greg I'm everyone's
friend no I want to stand out from the
rest of the key like I want respect
speak with the voice of the man respect
what loner say loners that like don't
have any friends I don't need friends
I can tell myself okay my cap all right
hey hey you're fortunate to be around me
in my awesome self it's so well
fortunate to be around the cast yeah but
I realize how to be here with you
whatever how it should have ended is one
of the greatest channels on YouTube I've
ever existed if you haven't seen this
and you're when you've seen my channel I
don't know how you how you've only seen
my channel knives pins or whatever okay
you go on chat sick cow drop their
straightener
should I spend it okay I think look it's
a marvelous country Witchcraft and
Wizardry
now let's go steal someone protected
book of dollar shall we mr. chameleon I
want a gas whistling rain going into the
library oh I can just take the book
right now should I grab it you sure I
guess pretty sure all handy yes yeah I
mean when you think about it we didn't
need to walk through the courtyard no I
guess not
hey and there's an infinity stone you're
sitting here on a pendant as well do you
want that too we crop yeah
and bring what you got for me oh I've
got some there is easy you ready
yeah no no you know what texting and
driving high speed winding road at night
really really bad I'll call you back in
like five minutes okay well here's them
super smart
yeah ha ha ha do you think that's funny
what's funny
did you lost your sling me ah thanks
clothes like you guys are no match for
the clover later
whoa too far wanting to attack the
victims choose your weapon oh I see
[Music]
yes oh whoa Dormammu
I've come to bargain mortars your vlog
leave earth take your eye makeup
followers with you and never come back
[Music]
you know they really should with the
warnings at the beginning just reading
watching my mind well you saved yeah but
that will be more dangerous to come one
of the ancient ones death was spread
throughout the multiverse those has no
sorceress supreme to defend it
yes only we had a device that could
reverse things their damage no yes no
yeah so I resurrected the angel
hello okay heard you like to dabble in
the Dark Dimension
you want to dabble in Dark Knight
dimension oh I'm not
well you reverse time to save the world
and someone special who died yes yes I
did and I also fix London and I fix my
hands I even rescued Batman from being
devoured by a high-pitched talking show
no yes that didn't
nevermind I see
yeah this little baby thing here there's
a lot I love turning back time to rescue
us it's so convenient and now that you
got that magic necklace you can pretty
much save everyone you can take
Quicksilver yep all the people who died
in sokovia you could say vision when you
get that Jim if does it what did you
think oh nothing with magic you can save
everything oh I'm afraid there are great
consequences one messes with the fabric
of time
like what though the Phil always comes
that would be 1215 Bordeaux what what
are you doing waiting table too many
and obviously I had to get a job at very
quit not being a sorceress sucks
don't please let me be huh that's right
I had so much money deal why because
your parents were rich because I
[Music]
yeah great job you guys
stand fast as amazing don't you love
when smart people making vegan videos
like Madison were doing because we dance
to rich everyone thanks for watching
hope you enjoyed it
this one one kind of a little work on
yeah otherwise yeah right now because
guy yeah we're working on how rope
they're working on how ruined what
should have ended agenda guys gotta
follow his day you gotta follow them you
know they bring up a great point this
point that I think other people brought
up and at the point that I left thinking
about how would dr. strange can just
reverse time that kind of I could come
restart the whole Marvel Universe yes he
could just save everything and everyone
yeah like he can solve any problem so
like let's say in infinity war when
Thanos is killing everyone they could
kill off everyone yeah estranged is he
gonna live is like well it's reverse
time they're gonna pull like an x-men
Days of Future past things exactly where
you know you just reverse everything on
them no one died yeah okay I am say yeah
there's nothing to do with this so like
at the end of x-men Days of Future past
when Logan comes back away right and
he's like oh my god gene isn't dead how
does the dead no one's this I knew that
was going to happen the second I saw the
trailer for that movie because if he's
going back to the 60s obviously nothing
none of that should happen it's always
going to change the future so what I was
either going to be alive like whenever
one the audience was like glue and I'm
like I knew about this a year ago when I
saw the thing is before you're kinda you
make a great point cuz I feel like I
feel like that how it could be with this
yeah I feel like they're gonna bring
back some dead characters I feel like
infinity War part 1 they'll kill off
some people and strange will just
resolve all the girls coming like you
didn't see that coming
whatever those better and a lot like you
try that actually
yeah eundel zadar maybe maybe please
please baby I like the song
having water swim group and also is how
it should have been it I love their
Batman characters oh I'll bet ya it is
not a family I feel like you know
because we're talking about possibly
dressing up as a certain vo for the
movie trivia Schmo down when we birth my
channel a certain character from what we
just saw
I might channel a character that's not
here but is in the DC Universe ah I'll
be giving away a little too much so what
we're going for
no we're not conniving people on the
Internet are smart I'm realistic I'm
going to spend 450 dollars in a costume
I might spend $200 I really like it
because we don't you hate to do prefer
to be in condition worthy you guys be a
hot poison ivy I am gonna make a great
one you guys no matter if it's a cheapo
costume or one that might cost me like
half my rent who knows it is a [ __ ] bill
are not important bills are short-term
yeah so the short mo down Walter
everybody the internet forever
you guys you two will never die so I
don't want to be doing forever I don't
have the energy to go on these stupid
shows and do and talk all this mess yeah
all these shows are do can talk about it
I said will you should definitely
subscribe your miss movie six series a
feature film based hour down there you
could follow it that's so Howard 2012's
L Howard 2012 on Twitter and Fe feel
Howard NaCl Howard on Twitter introduced
again yeah in the same kid we talked
about this group or before we started
you want to check your little Mike again
see if it's working
whatever you do I don't know what he
does all the time he likes dead
something and then he's just making sure
I don't know I don't know what's
happening I don't know I just like judge
me on like three different areas I don't
know I know I think your channels great
this is great who shaft
great everything's happening is
wonderful my hair really does blend in
with the couch no no you look ball it's
like the exact opposite I'm just talking